人が働きもになる仕組みを考えれるかどう
かだと思うよ素直な心何に対して素直なの
か僕はやっぱ黄金率なんですよねだって何
のために誰のためになぜあなたは経してる
んですかって青木サの人生系哲学100回
聞いたら豊かになる
話今回はですね経営者として絶対に磨いた
方が良い能力というものを1つ上げるとし
たら弊社の方に何の天才になりなさいと
いう風
[音楽]
にまやっぱりそれは人でしょう人の生かし
方結局経営ってのは人に働いてもらわ
なければならない仕事ですよねなんだろう
その人が働きもになる仕組みを考えれるか
どうかだと思うのよアチーブメントという
会社は税引語利益の3割を社員に分配し
てるよねこれね僕はね計算でやってないん
ですよ社員を物心共に豊かにしたいと思っ
てるんですよ目的なんですよ経営の目的が
そこにあるんですよだお客様にともかく
誠実でありたいお客様の信頼お客様が
アチーブメントを選んでくださったことに
対しては100%その信頼に答えたい本当
にそう思ってますで社員もともかく
アチーブメントという会社を選んでくれた
以上はこの会社で良かったと本当に青木
社長信じてこの会社に入ってよかったと心
からそう思ってもらいたいから社会にとっ
てもなくてはならない会社でありたい工学
納税法人であり事業そのものもなくては
ならない事業だとあの会社の事業は世の中
に必要だと本当に心からそう思ってるでも
結局この社会これ人の集まりじゃないです
か会社も人の集まりじゃないですか結局
個人の集合体じゃないですかってことは
1人1人が幸せウェルビング向上的な幸福
感を味わえるかどうかっていうのが全ての
基本だと思うんですよだから経営者って
いうのはまそういう意味では株主に対する
責任も持っているしお取引先に対しての
責任も持っているあの私は松下孝之助をね
とても尊敬してます松下孝之助という方は
松下電気の創業者ですよね9歳でデチ暴行
そっから世界の松下を作り上げたんだけど
松下孝之助さんはなんておっしゃってる
かって言うと心理に対して従順であること
を素直と言う素直とはただ何に対しても
従順であることではないと何が正しいかを
見極めてそれに従う心の要素であると素直
になる心を極めるならば人はそう明になり
強くなるとでこの素直な心何に対して素直
なのか僕はやっぱ黄金率なんですよね何事
でも人々からして欲しいと望む通りのこと
を他の人々にもそのようにしなさいと
バイブルにはあるんですよま私は原理原則
目に見えない存在力がこの宇宙にはあると
思ってるんだけどその目に見えない誰もが
これはこうあるべきだよねていうことを
実行できる自分でありたいと思ってるよね
私あの経済同友会のメンバーなんだけどね
僕を経済同友会に紹介してくれたのは元
IBMのね社長やった北代さんと星野
リゾートの星野さんで星野さんがね
こないだあの面白いメッセージをしたの
やっぱり教科書通りにやったら経営者は
成功するその問いだなと思いますよだ教科
書の中に1番大事なことは人だってだ人
っていうのが優先順位の最上位にできない
ところに苦労があるんだと思うよだって何
のために誰のためになぜあなたは経してる
んですかて金のためでも金って何のために
必要なんですかて愛する人を幸せにする
ためじゃないその愛する人の対象が松下コ
さんが言う原理原則で言う正しいこと
正しいことに従順なのが素直であると
正しいことっていうのはお客様にとっても
社員にとってもお取先にとっても株主に
とっても社会にとっても全てのステーク
ホルダーにとっても良いことでありそれ
自分にとっても良いことでなおかつ今だけ
ではなくこれから先も良いことだって言っ
てるわけだからそれを追求することが経営
者にとって必要なこと1番大切なこといや
もっと言うとじゃあ別の言い方をすると
心理に対して従順なことなんじゃないの
経営者にとって1番大事なことはそれは僕
なりに言うと経営の目的は人を幸せにする
ことだということなんで人って言っただけ
であって本来は心理に対して原理原則に
従順であることそれがおそらく経営者に
とって1番大切なことなのではないかなと
思いますねうんありがとうございますこれ
まで様々な経験をされてこられる中でなん
かその1番大切なことは人を大切にする
ことであるっていうのはなんかいつの時点
で気づいてそこにこうすごく注力をして
[音楽]
いらまこれ個人的なことがやっぱり29歳
の時に僕はバイブルと出会ったことだよね
それで僕は愛とということが分かったから
それまでは力だったんだトップセールス
トップマネージャーともかく力で
のし上がってやろうと思ってたからね
勝ち負けなんですよやっぱり自分中心だっ
たと思いますま今も十分自分中心なと思う
んだけどもいや人間ってね競技の利己主義
か講義の利己主義いしも利己主義なんです
よただ今は講義の利己主義という表現を
使ってもいいかなというキャリアになった
よねだ自分だけのために生きてんではない
とそういうことなんだと思うだみんなに
とっていいことを優先できるってことだと
うんだそれやっぱり29歳の時にバイブル
と出会ってまあその中で移植足りて冷戦を
知るでどうなのかなでもやっぱり40代の
半ば過ぎて初めてそういうところに
落ち着いたいんじゃないかなだからお金の
苦労も丸25年以上僕お金の苦労全くして
ないのでだ100回聞いた豊かになる話を
本当に100回聞いて私が伝えてる心髄を
掴んでもらえたら絶対金の苦労はしなく
なりますこれは僕は断言しますただ100
回聞ける人は多分100人のうち5人しか
いないと思う大体3回ぐらいで終わるん
じゃない3回か4回5回ぐらいじゃないか
うちの受行生だと230回聞いてくれるか
もしれないなそんなに人の話ってね興味
ないよ僕が言ってる美容室のね人に聞い
たらねあこないだ見ましたよって何回
ぐらい見てんのったら2回ぐらいですかね
つってたも僕の体治療してくれてる人にも
あのねどう見てるつったらあ見てますよて
何回ぐらい見たた3回ぐらいですてそんな
もんだよ本当に豊かになれるよって言っ
てるわけ俺これ戸田さんがいなかったら
この企画ないんだから早期がいないとない
しね岡口はいないとこれ今で僕話してない
これ無償で喋ってんだよYouTubeで
なんで俺見ないのかなてもったいないなと
思うよいやマジに私の講座3日間でもう
6万人以上ね受行してくれてますよね私は
今育てたねトレーナーが今5人
トレーニングやってますけれど私の講座は
今経営者しか参加できないけれどで3日間
で数10万払ってもらってるわけじゃない
ですか無償ですからね100回聞いても
無料ですからでもこれ大事なことなんです
よもらった本は読まない無料ってねあまり
価値を見出さないですよ人はでも本当は実
は無料でも価値があるものは価値があると
でもその価値ってね人から押し付けられる
もんじゃないのでうん自分の中でやっぱり
求めないものは手に入らないそれが
やっぱり実態だよ
[音楽]
ねま結局僕は人って言ったけど究極は
やっぱり心理に対して従順であるという
なんか心理なんて言うと宗教ぽい表現に
なってしまうんだけれどもやっぱり1番
大切なものを見失わずに大切に仕切
るってことだと思うんだよ僕はそこに生き
ていきたいと思ってます俺は絶対プライド
あるからこれからもっと社員を豊かにし
ます今も社員はいや社長十分豊かにして
くれもらってますっていう社員多いですよ
うちはそういう風な心の状態をみんな持っ
てくれてるに恵まれてるんででもこんな
もんじゃないよってみんな見てごらんて
いや僕は正直こっからだよ40期
アチーブメントはねまた次のステージに
入りますでも僕は絶対ね能力開発の専門家
としてねアチーブメントを最高の作品にし
ますえコメント欄そしてチャンネル登録も
よろしくお願いし
[音楽]
ますまあなかなかね経営者っていうのは
ある意味で経営を学ぶ場だとか経営という
ものの答えってなかなか人から与えられる
もんではないので難しいところもあると
思うんですけど僕は絶対ね研修とか書籍だ
とかこうYouTubeだとか私の
YouTubeだけじゃなくて多くの
素晴らしいYouTubeがあるので勉強
した方がいいと思います経営者はね勉強
熱心プラス思考素直これあの昔船幸夫先生
がおっしゃったことだけどこれ絶対私も
大事にしてきてることなのであの学び続け
てもらいたいなと思います